so welcome to the last day warning
session and
um
I learned from Morris that we shall all
say please subscribe to the YouTube
channel
exactly so
um
put Simon's like the talks
all right all right so
um waking us up with a little bit of a
discussion with maybe
some controversial uh thoughts maybe not
we'll see feel free to interrupt me as
always
um
and I can start by saying that
slowly I won't have the answer to this
right
don't hold your breath
um but but this is sort of the context
because
um as you or some of you know who um I
talked to before I worked a lot in the
applied context and uh and the the
question there in a way is always this
one right can we do this and how is that
relative to what we do currently or
people get carried away in the
discussion and forget to compare it to
what they're doing currently right
that's another element of this
um so the applied context in which I
have had most of these discussions or
not though not all of them is that of
um
profiling the unemployed and I I say
profiling with a little bit of a
hesitation because the EU AI act just
told us no more profiling so in a way
um the we
people working in that space might need
to use different language in the future
I don't think it will change what they
actually do
um the the the motivation there is that
unemployment agencies
um at least in Germany but also many
other oecd countries they uh you know
try to streamline and make the process
more efficient on how to allocate people
who fall out of employment or have been
out of employment for a long time uh
into I to two things either a welfare
benefit program of sorts you know or
some interventions to re-skill them or
to assign them to new jobs right so
those are the two um prediction problems
if you will and
um and the in Germany the context is
that these are really very localized
activities so every Community has that
little job center
um and uh I mean really small
communities and which is to be a sign
outside in one person sitting inside
right and then you walk in and tell them
your story and then they do something
and and it's not hard to imagine that
that's very subjective depending on how
well the people are trained to work in
these job centers
um
and it can be incredibly inefficient
Plus
what is the the history of experience
they have in Consulting with people uh
that come in and need job when they make
these recommendations right so it's very
sensible to think well let's use you
know the millions and millions of people
who have gone through this process and
the many decisions that have been made
to learn right in the localized level
um the there has been the first wave of
attempts to solve this problem was to
make rule-based decision guidelines you
know if you if they have been without a
job for this amount of time then this
kind of training program might work into
life
um but not hard for this community to
imagine that that can be quite
inefficient
um still and so the Hope really is and I
would say still is
that we could solve algorithmically or
with the knowledge of data uh any of
these problems or all of them that it is
more efficient effective and objective
um there have been a lot of countries in
which yeah
yeah this is a selection of countries of
which I know this has been tried I'm
sure there are others
um the most recent case is Austria and
that's sort of a little bit like our
um our Compass case you know
in a different application setting but
hugely disputed in the Press
interestingly not so much for the actual
agreement decision making but for the
fact that data is used in privacy
privacy policy right I mean it's Europe
after all so we're still Europeans we're
still having the history we have and and
so that was what what killed it and that
it got revived and then it was modified
and I mean so this is this is our prime
example but
um in Germany
um
the system is quite similar to Austria
and uh in the 10 years that I've worked
in or partially worked in the institute
for employment researchers especially
the research arm of the employment
agency the discussion how to deal with
this problem came
On In Waves you know it feels like every
five years when new directors come in
there's another attempt to get this
going and then it dies again and so
so this is for context right
um we discussed this week a lot uh
issues with that Pipeline and where's
Emily there you are Emily uh was kind
enough to shorten my talk a lot or allow
me to focus about something else because
she already told us with this beautiful
graph about all the decisions that have
to be made sort of in the middle section
right what made me smile was you know
seeing that little disc here not because
I'm so old that this at some point was
an innovation compared to what we used
before but um because
it still starts with this
and there's so many decisions that
happened before the data get on that
disk that um that is easy to overlook
right and and so I thought I focus on
these other two sets where a lot of
people are also involved that make
decisions that influence this process
and uh that might be good to have on
one's radar or to When developing these
systems talk to these people ahead of
time so that you can avoid some of the
problems right so that's the that's the
goal here
these questions or the three questions
that I want to ask I answer well I guess
pose to us here for discussion is um
the larger scope on what we are using to
guide the prediction in the context of
the question of the talk right what is
the algorithm using what would be the
human using when when she makes that
decision and likewise
what affects our perception at the end
you know whether this is fair whether
this is okay whether this is acceptable
right because both of these are key to
structuring the middle path correctly
and then a little bit of a discussion on
can we improve the whole thing so that
uh that that they will make make some
progress in using this correctly so
for the first segment
um whatever using to guide the
prediction there are a couple of
things I want to point out one is
clearly we're using guiding principles
right and I had a hard time deciding
whether I put them at the front or at
the end because it has sort of relevant
for both of these but I decided to put
them on the front
um
mostly so that I don't forget I say will
say the least about them um but what is
interesting and and
um
last night we discussed this a little
bit
um
I
it seems to me or I guess you had that
experience too moving to Germany that
that our
lens on Justice is a little different
one Phoenix is a little different
um because we and I learned that
yesterday what the roots could be for
that but
um
uh Moritz hypothesis was that you know
the in the absence of a civil rights
movement and sort of a clear group of
people that you try to protect or uh you
know promote
um it is a little less clear what it is
that we are looking for when we try to
promote fairness yet everyone wants to
promote fair and it's not that we don't
use this term you know I mean that could
be good new uh stereotype about the
Germans but that's not the case right I
mean we do try to do it but it's you
never quite know what what people have
in their head when they talk about this
right are they talking about in the
labor market context are they talking
about you know that uh This Job Program
should be allocated such that on job
Seekers eventually they have the chance
to find a job or should they be
allocated so that um it is relative to
the contribution they made to the
unemployment benefit program the number
of years they have been enrolled and
contributed to it or if the allocation
is
um made based on the regional and
socio-demographic background
characteristics of what have right and
in each of these decision rules would
fall into a different
philosophical corner of what the guiding
principle is right and and what is
interesting about that is that you you
would you know obviously evaluate your
algorithm quite differently depending on
what principle you're using and in this
in the in the labor market context we've
seen this in you know uh
discuss this at links I guess in that
paper um what what these different
decision principles would mean for the
algorithm as we plan them right but what
is interesting is again human versus
machine
with these individualized local and
Regional job centers we don't have this
discussion even right it's popping up
now because we are using or want to use
a machine and all in a sudden we notice
hey wait a minute you know we have never
had that conversation what it is that
it's trying to do here right and so in
that sense I I mean if nothing happens
with implementing these algorithms
that's a useful outcome at least in
practice that I'm watching happening uh
in you know among these labor market
um
organizations and presumably in other
contexts too but this is the only
context I can speak for and I this also
uh
let us sort of to to to think that it
might be helpful that we you know when
we talk about these
these models and the decisions and where
the problem arises that we sort of
separate I mean at least with respect to
these ethical principles that we
separate that out you know from you know
the actual prediction times and then the
decision tasks that we do using these
models and obviously there's a bit of an
interaction yeah
you're saying so let's say we use an
algorithm or whatever procedure we use
and predict
s within the labor market somebody's
going to be let's give an example good
employee and then whether this is
actually
right so there is there's a
there's a step here that
often prevents us from doing the things
exactly how we want to do this right I
mean we can't support a quarter of a
person because there are other
constraints about the world that guide
what kind of suggestion well in this
localized labor market context you could
imagine well the prediction would be
this person should really have this kind
of job but it would require a move from
Southern Germany to Northern Germany and
so you know it constrains the actual
implementation of that decision right so
there are a lot of things
yeah I mean some of it I mean some of it
you could fold into the prediction task
right you could do this all stratified
or what have you but
um but at least when we looked at all
the documentation how these decisions
are implemented it seems like there's a
lot of sort of adjustment to the real
world happening in the very end I don't
know first of if you want to add
something to that but um that's
basically uh what we noticed right that
it doesn't stop there because there's
there's a lot of where the world is
moving as we do this right and the
situation changes and therefore the
implementation will be quite different
yeah
okay
um okay so this is the the principle is
one element that we use when we um
plan to use these algorithms the bigger
one and uh more sort of in my wheelhouse
is uh the data we are using to do this
and
um in this particular labor market
context
the data uh
usually comes from
uh the social the the the
Social Security Administration
contributions right so
people get employed and so we have
excellent data also available for
research for everybody
um since 1972 who is not self-employed
or a civil servant so everyone else is
who is in the normal social security
system we have uh records from 72
onwards on a daily basis where they work
and how much they earn right those two
values are phenomenally good because
that's what people later on use to get
their pension and they're making sure
that the records are okay everything
else in that database not so much I'll
come to that in a moment but the problem
is that obviously well let me move to
this thing the problem is that we have
this and since 72 a lot has happened in
Germany right it and certainly when I
moved in 2000 from Germany to the US it
was a very wide country and very few
immigrants and that has changed quite a
bit you know like the the
um
Refugee waves being won but also just
regular Labor uh movement and and
uh and so
for certain groups we have a lot fewer
records and shorter histories right and
the labor market has changed quite a bit
there was a big dynamic in uh how the
the labor market composition is what
kind of job so so the amount of data you
have to learn from is quite different by
the various groups but also by the kind
of tasks you're trying to predict and
that that is a problem is no news to
this community here right many of you
have seen this graph before this is from
uh the the various facial recognition
systems and um the notion of the
hypothesis is that these systems are not
so great in predicting uh certain shades
of skin tone for
um
females because they have fewer training
data available for those who have been
right and
um I have seen it was interesting to see
that for me because we have in the
survey context done a study where we uh
um
recorded the vocal inaction between an
interview and a respondent and when an
interviewer I mean these days no one
picks up the phone anymore but back in
the days when you did and actually had
surveys on the phone uh the interviewers
often would not dare to ask you for your
gender because
um it feels a little awkward when you
call someone and there's sort of the
notion that you should recognize the
gender by talking to them right and or
by their voice right and and when you
hear the recordings of these interviews
you hear the some interviews who or
institutions who force people to ask
about gender to say it's like oh I'm
sorry I have to ask that but you know
Omar are you male or female right and um
but what we did is we had for I don't
remember roughly five thousand or ten
thousand people we had the the estimate
of the interview and then later on the
self-recording right I made a
self-report of the gender and we saw the
exact same effect you know
African-American females were
misclassified by the interviews at much
higher rate right and and the linguists
told us well it's you know different
vocal cords you know like different use
of language different you know so so but
by and large fewer training data for
um for the interviewer and so they're
just not used to
hearing the sound and classifying the
sound makes total sense right it's not I
mean it looks like racism but you could
argue it's also just lack of training
right and um and so so so that was
interesting for me to see that the the
visual and the audio kind of had the um
the same effect and
should have brought you those data but
anyway
the point I want to make is that while
we have increasingly
many streams of data that we are using
for these prediction tasks
some of them I really thought you know
and I mean it I had to smile when the
German government during covet said oh
let's use fitbits and measure heart
rates and what have you and I'm like
let's not do that because who is it that
has a Fitbit right it's probably those
that suffer the most from covet
um anyway so we have a lot of holes in
the data and
I think you know as statisticians we we
or well
can I make that claim we mostly think
about well more likely to think about
holes in the data as they come from
entire units missing or entire answer
missing right but the the the the the
lack of quality in the data is has also
a different aspect which is we we often
have very poor measurements and even if
people report US
whatever group we assign them to that
reporting might also be flawed and um so
both on the measurement side and the
unit side and here's one example
apologies for the acronyms this is the
national longitudinal survey of use this
is a big survey in the US that has been
done by the Bureau of Labor Statistics
for many many many many years it's
actually new cohort uh in the making
right now and this is the current
population survey which is the largest
data collection that's used to sort of
get unemployment figures and whatnot
reason I brought this rather old picture
uh from Hurricane I know this um
what you see here is the number of
people in certain age groups
h0 to 35 in this case
that were identified as being present in
the household when the interviewer
called and tried to make an interview
right with the completely random sample
the exact same design
and this line here the another slide
you see here it has sort of a weird dip
compared to the red to the other one
right
this survey has a screener that says I'm
looking for people age 15 to 21.
in the introduction
it yeah
I
I and lsy also that they remain
participants for multiple waves this
first and recruitment this is just for
initial equipment it's not drop out
later on yeah so that's another problem
but what I want to point out is here we
have seen this in other surveys so the
health and retirement service they call
up and say it's like we're looking for
people between you know 55 and something
rather and then you see the dip at age
55 right I mean this goes just to the
misreporting the respondent one easy way
to get out of a survey is to say oh
no one here in the household fits that
okay rather than to say it's like I
don't want to do the interview
or if you have more sophisticated we can
hide it a bit and then do antioxide
rosters and then you have droppers and
whatnot but yeah but I really think it's
just the young people that are dropping
out of the
um the multi-wave surface right like not
to participate right I couldn't not just
be explained because they're sort of the
requirement that they're present for
another year or two when they get called
up and they're saying this is a server
over so many years absolutely you know
your kid is about to move out yeah yeah
this is page 19 or it's 17 yeah they'll
say no because my chicken is not going
to be around in the year 100 agree that
is an effect we see this screenshot of
data is at the screening stage before
they even know that this is a multi-wave
thing or before they even
this is not the number of respondents is
just whom they found at screening you
know like they recorded that because
they think we're trying to figure out
why is it that we don't find these
people you know and so they looked at
this early phase of the recruitment but
you're absolutely right I mean later on
they drop out and whatnot so what you're
describing is the kind of unit
non-responsible problem that we see
because they they drop out at a higher
rate this one is my clearly failed
attempt to show the measurement error
problem that even if we find them
initially they might not tell us who
they are and then not be surveyed or
they report it later on I mean in a
different survey you might just
misreport belonging to a certain group
because you don't want to reveal you
know like have you ever had an abortion
nope you know and then you're not in the
abortion group right I mean that's as
easy as that right the more sensitive it
gets the more likely it might be that I
just misreport pretty easy and and for
that reason you know the the Summerfield
of social scientists excited about all
these other data streams you have but
it's not necessarily getting better with
other data streams because then we
collectively make up the feature out of
that stream and who knows how good that
is or actually we know that it's often
not good one problem that we have you
know whether it's the missed reports or
the people missing entirely is that
how do we get information about the rest
right and uh
a common vehicle is you know to use
proxy reports I believe you mentioned
that uh also
um we had and it can sometimes be
successful I wanted to uh just briefly
show you what we did in this big covet
survey that we uh did worldwide there we
we did you know we recruited
with the bias sample via the Facebook
platform people into the survey asking
them about how they do with covet and
then one question uh was you know
do you personally know anyone in your
local community sort of uses social
sensing mechanism rather than asking
only about people themselves and what we
saw later on and apologize this is way
too small for this uh the screen here
but basically what you see here is from
May to December the in Black the actual
uh coveted waves in uh all these
countries is starting with Spain and
ending with Tanzania here and then each
of these variables that we had in the
prediction model
um and we saw
um
that that this edition of asking about
the community really improved the
prediction because of the buy its
sampleness right so a combination of
measurement and data collection can help
you mitigate these problems but you have
to think about the problems prior in
order to to get there so now turning
back to the human right we still have a
setting where
someone might not have enough data I
said that every at the very beginning
right and the problem is we already know
a lot about human judgment and we know
that they use heuristics to make
judgments right and I mean I'm sure that
many of these biases are familiar to you
um they have been discussed in the
psychology uh in other literatures for
so long that they've become common
knowledge but
I think it's still fascinating to me how
often we forget that in pretty much
every situation this can arise right um
we would Christopher and I recently did
some experiments uh in the labeling
context you know where we had people
rates uh hatefulness uh or whether
cheats are hateful or show offensive
language and you clearly see that you
know the the autumn
has a big effect if you see less hateful
tweets at the beginning then you create
the subsequent ones um
differently than uh when you see more
hateful tweets at the beginning this is
very simple uh experiment but the the
point is that these humans in the job
centers they also saw someone else right
before on that very chair and made a
decision about that person and and so
these you know subsequent policies we
often don't talk about or at least I see
the folks that are trying to implement
the algorithms don't talk about when
they try to evaluate uh the the
performance of the algorithm uh compared
to
um the human
in the survey context and thanks to
Emily we discussed this yesterday and I
thought let me throw in this graph after
all because I I was so excited about the
attack Emily when you showed us you know
the first attempt at sort of building a
framework in in in making sure at least
we know where to look for the errors
right and and as I shared with you in
the survey context we've done this for a
long time along the pipeline of survey
data protection protection
production to look at the area sources
and in our Casio in general I think it
might have been a bit of a disservice to
always just call it error not separated
out into variants and bias at each of
these steps because
they have met at each of these steps and
the different medication mechanisms uh
possible depending on what it is but I
do think it could be useful to have for
um the algorithmic decision making
context something along those lines you
know and and in particular think about
the data as the input stream and how the
data collection really can affect this I
I um because we're talking of the
multi-group context here
and we rely so heavily on the
demographic data um I thought it could
be useful you know to point out simple
things that it that are easy to a not
know or B overlooked
um when demographic data are collected
here's an example from the 20 children
census compared to the 20 20 census and
those people you know who who work a lot
with census they don't know that the
census tries to improve the way they ask
the raising intensity questions from
decade to decade to sort of keep up with
the wording right but what is maybe a
little less known is that also the way
the data entry happens changed over time
and so for example you know when people
rode in Mexican black and Colombian in
in their response right in 2010 this
would have been coded as Mexican and
Colombian because they just didn't take
more characters right in in 2020 you
would have seen all three okay I mean
it's just who would have thought that
right and it's it's sort of simple data
collection elements that
if you knee deep into theoretical
computer science you know how would you
know right I mean do you have enough
papers to lead you don't need to read
these methods reports but that's later
the Multiverse groups that we are
comparing to right and and and I mean
this is just a simple example and it
gets of course even more complicated
right now there's a big discussion in
the context of the Dei
um diversion Equity inclusion
initiatives
remember last year at April the current
census director of Santos was at the
panel discussion they were really honing
in on the fact he's like well what are
we doing there when we measure income or
other categories and say that's what
that's how we measure amounts right I
mean we we go by dollar amounts that you
earn but maybe in certain communities
that's not the currency that creates
value maybe it is the number of social
connections you have maybe it's you know
whatever you're standing in the
community on in so so who are we right
to classify and say these are the groups
that matter and you know since that is a
discussion that we had throughout the
week I think it could be helpful to sort
of rethink what you know what
measurement are we using when with the
data that happened on that disk that you
have okay
so that's um the uh the the first set of
things on the input stream that I wanted
to point out
on the output stream
clearly you know even if we were to be
able to quantify
quality of the fairness of the human
versus the machine and all of that you
know with the input stream with what
happens in the decision-making process
then there's still sort of a question on
how how do people perceive it later on
right because they're not going to look
under the hood and they don't care what
you tell them and so
we thought we'd ask the people you know
why not and um and we we did this using
a vignette study where we had uh
scenarios like this one here local
employment agency has developed a
computer program for assigning support
measures to job Seekers this program
uses data about persons past periods of
employment and unemployment as well as
information available on the internet
um staff members blah blah blah compares
the information makes a decision whether
you receive support or not and what we
did in this vignette study that we
changed the context so this unemployment
context is one we did this for the
banking context we did this for Britain
Conte I mean
um
yeah I guess uh sentencing
um in for
um job seeking I mean so this is job
seeking for the unemployment benefits
setting and then we varied uh who
um what action is taking whether the the
action is assistive or supportive or
whether it's punitive we varied what
type of data is used whether it's just
analog data that belong to the
organization or it's you know external
data sources that you can fin find and
link to and whether the recider is uh a
person or an algorithm or the
combination of the two and you know I
mean someone said that this this week
it's like amazing how well I think Abby
you said that how how cheap big tech
companies can get bad data well this is
not cheap data and it's actually pretty
good data uh this is a huge what we call
a probability based uh um sample in
Germany it is a multi-stage recruitment
where first regions in Germany are in
let me selected and then within each and
region either random samples from the
municipal registry or from a random walk
not the computer science type but
actually people walking with the um on
the through the streets and writing down
every fifth household and then
recruiting people into the survey the
recruitment happens face to face with
the 50-minute interviewer for anyone in
the household age 16 to 75 and then
of course we have you know
not everyone stays on these panels
forever so they are refresher waves and
to get the numbers back up but the at
least the recruitment process is pretty
good for what you can get in terms of
service right so that that just this was
not an M took we pay 25 cents for like
100 clicks yeah survey and so what we
did is with this group of people who um
they were exposed to these vignettes
with the different contexts the
different actions uh the different data
types and the different actors and um
and look you know how do they rate
fairness how do they rate acceptability
of this process right and and and what
you see here in this graph is I think
this should be readable right uh yeah uh
that sort of up here this is the pure
the only the algorithm decides the
middle part is both human and algorithm
decides and then solely the human and
what was interesting for us is this
First Column here that the banking
context where we know of many people in
Germany also know that this has been
done right I mean we are quite used to
loan processes or we call it chufa uh
this credit scoring uh element that that
something of that type is at Place yeah
missed with the internet versus no
internet yeah so this is the data type
whether it's the offline data that the
agency has you know so the bank has
about you or the employment agency
versus other data that might they might
find from you on the internet right
admittedly
maybe not the best wooding the way we
put this in the vignettes there so
there's always the tension how much can
you explain briefly before they stop
reading what the prompt is and um and so
that's what we settled on but um that
was the difference between these two
data times
yeah so so let's take the banking
context right so this would be should
you get a loan or not right and uh and
we tell in the vignette that a human
with the assistance of an algorithm
right is deciding whether
um you get the loan help me what was the
punitive phrasing what did we tell them
they they get fined for something right
I I remember anyway so so whether it's
an assistive action or a punitive action
um and then whether they they in that
process internet
data or external data sources from the
internet are used versus the data that
they have from like past transactions at
the bank or you know like the the the
actual data in the employment context it
would be
um you know uh
in in in
um
increased well for help versus uh you
know
yeah okay
so the rating um these 4 000 people that
participated in the survey when we did
it in 2021 they gave a rating on a five
point scale where they uh said that it's
um
uh not fair at all you know somewhat
fair and so it's a Five Points rating
and what you see here is sort of the
average fitness rating of the people who
were exposed to living yet not everybody
get we randomized the vignettes to the
people who would otherwise be too hard
of a task but uh we had about 1500
ratings for each of the
um this scenarios I believe
um and uh and this is sort of the
average rating and the gray uh box this
year those were
um this is the prison context because we
um we we thought it was
to absurd the scenario that would have
created the additional punitive
statement I mean that decision making I
think it was a bail and we didn't want
to go uh in the other direction was for
the German context just not feasible we
tried it out in the pre-test and people
were like what are you asking about yes
the line is using or they just know that
this is a human and the Machine together
that's all they know so it's just a
perception it's just exactly it's just
the perception right and and
here too I mean it's interesting when
you try to measure perception right how
much information do you give them sure
we could have set them down walk them
through the algorithm right we voted for
um
we hold it for a setting that's closer
to what's happening currently right
people don't know right these things are
in place in some you know you read about
it in the news but you don't know how
the algorithm works but if you have some
expert to explain
so so these are the the people who would
be affected by the decision it's not the
ones that that make the decision this
would be
anyone you pick from the street who's
unemployed walks in the unemployment
office and now is paged with the
situation is this just a human judging
me or is the human working with the
computer and then gives me a suggestion
I'm just saying that the same like those
are people who will be affected the
support
that we watch on YouTube videos
oh totally I mean it could be entirely
different entirely different but that's
not the world we live in right I mean
right now we don't have well warrants
will record them now that you are the
YouTube stuff since Wednesday with our
life but yes of course we could explain
hopefully we will get there and maybe at
some point now that you know the last
language models are in the use news
every day
um maybe this is already different we're
actually repeating the study right now
as we speak so that we have
um you know in two-year intervals a
measurement of this perception right and
yeah this is this is not a trade this is
a perception moment in time in 2021
absolutely
the reason
I'm showing this and not honing in so
much on these actual numbers is that I
think what's interesting here is that
the perception is so different depending
on the context right this is not in in
in in the EU regulation context we are
talking about this
almost context-free and are about to
make the same
mistake let me say that as we did with
gdapr when we judge data to be
sensitive or an alternative or you know
like context independent I mean Helen is
not here but I'm channeling my in a
Nissan bound and this is you know like
we we gotta look at the context and in
some settings
it you know it seems reasonable to do
and people are okay with it already now
yeah I maybe lost the thread but are the
respondents uh prompted on like
or is it just sort of you just say like
like okay
you can we make this is sort of the kind
of conversation you would have at a
party when you briefly talk about this
right I mean this is this is not an exam
this is not we're not testing knowledge
we are not they're just
reaction to this you know
people are very worried about algorithms
making all decisions alone but they
prefer any algorithms and humans
together over humans in certain contexts
so uh in well in certain contexts more
than in other so I think the way you
phrase it was our conclusion too from
the study and the the sneak peek at the
new data still seems to confirm that but
um the the it's still varies by context
right so I mean various here but it also
varies here right and you know we
did all the what statistician do
modeling you know to see if the relative
effects and you know holding sitting
into control and whatnot and what what
we do see indeed right that the
combination of human machine uh is
generally seen better across all the
contexts
um that that it they really don't like
this in the job interesting setting and
uh but there are some interesting
interactions going on right and the
other
um so
Baseline here would be the banking
context and everything else is perceived
more negative those are the coefficients
from that
um multi-level ordinal regression model
that we had here
um
because we are in this multi-group
context here I want to also show that
um it does give a little bit by
demographic groups how this is perceived
we had strong hypotheses on uh certain
demographic groups including uh foreign
nationality that that more vulnerable
groups would would be a little more
alert insensitive to that we didn't find
these strong effects in the way that we
have we thought they would be there
um but we you know depending on the
context we saw a few effects on age and
gender groups uh in this perception
the context-specific piece and I
couldn't help but to actually bring some
research with Helen because
I really feel strongly about this EU
regulation discussion and how in the
gdpr context we Overlook the context and
we overlooked how people's perception
might change to your point right over
time and as they learn we might see this
differently and we did try a similar
study
in not perception on fairness for an ADM
system but data willingness to share
data right and um we had
in 2019 asked
in a similar quality survey whether
people are willing to share
data about themselves to combat a
pandemic right 2019.
and then nice you know as like if
economists would want to have it then
something happens and then you can look
afterwards this is like and and then we
did the study again right and we saw
this so this is 2019 and this is 2020
right and we saw
clear shifts from not acceptable to
share the data to more acceptable both
in the longitudinal setting and the two
contractional sets of data that we use
right and to me this to speak strongly
like it just
also not just philosophically but also
empirically just does not make sense to
discuss this without the context yes
if you could elaborate a little bit of
what you just said on how you think that
these should impact legislation because
it's not clear to me that legislation
a lot of perceptions and it becomes very
positive perception of something
happening that means they should be
allowed I agree that's and thank you for
allowing me to make that clear I didn't
mean that we should even more than we
already do make policies based on
opinion polls this is if you take that
away that would be the wrong takeaway
that's not what I'm trying to say but
what I'm what I'm trying to say and what
we've seen in the gdpr context is that
we have very strong data protection
regulations in place right now but but
they ignore the context and that for
certain purposes it really would be a
lot better for everybody if data could
flow more naturally from one data holder
to the next take a medical context right
one doctor to the next you sign a lot of
paperwork for that information to be
able to flow right now in Germany right
in in a way that it really has harmed US
during prohibit in general is very
secular
the the
similarly the the algorithm decision
making
it has a bit of a context discussion but
more of the context is this a decision
about a human versus not a human and not
in which context right is this a
decision where you know
in an hour from now I need to know
whether what health decision I made
because you're about to die or is this a
situation in which I'm bad with coming
up with examples on the fly but it you
know what I mean and this this sort of
context specific in in town this amount
of argument in the privacy or data
sharing context result is that you have
to know not individual perception but
sort of General underlying Norms because
if you do violate the Norms that will
cause disruption in society or whatever
you know and and I think the same is
true here too in in the EDM contest
does that make sense
okay
um so
another element aside from the Norms is
so how good are these predictions
someone
I think Emily you will ask right what's
the R square of these models
and I believe you couldn't pull that up
out of you know your head in that moment
if you were
a social scientist
you would have said 0.2 because
every paper you read in your
undergraduate sociology classes sort of
have a point to a prediction uh you know
R square it turns out that's still true
and in uh Mass collaboration study that
uh Matt salganic organized
using
data from The Fragile family challenge a
project family study they use data on
you know roughly 4 000 people
12 000 variables so lots of information
over time age from birth to age nine and
then had hundreds of teams
challenge to predict an outcome at age
15. okay using whatever technique you
might want to use crystal ball
regression
keep learning whatever right take your
pick right
and this is what they found
you know
the best I mean like no matter what was
used there you know it's it's 0.2 or
less the R square right the predictive
power of these models
is just very long
and and I think that's something
you chew on a little bit sorry
in this case predicting
um outcomes at age 15 about the children
all of these hundreds of like you know
civil
there were all kinds of like um so these
are the different outcomes this is
predicting GPA this is uh predicting a
material hardship this was predicting
education this was predicting job
training layouts but the models of it
yeah
for what you're predicting what happens
to them at age 15 yes correct but does
somebody have a job at age 15 job
training what kind of job training
it wasn't me for a 15 year old to get
laid off
that problem
[Music]
it's a family service correct family
seven yeah so this is not meant as a
statement about the models this is meant
about like the data and the underlying
labels that like
the nature is like unpredictable here
like there's a lot of uncertainty
exactly and and so I mean the models
were good you know they did you know I
mean they did the whole game you know
how you put these do this certainly
state-of-the-art modeling that they're
in there some of them might have been
very poor you know
um that that
I guess the takeaway here is like even
if they try very hard you know and we
expose the different talents and we have
thousands of variables
and many of them are measured good I
mean this is a good survey this is you
know compared to your average internet
data very good service right
but of course this you know again World
happens no it happens you know and it's
just theories aren't that good I mean it
could be any of these you know it's it's
they try to dissect what could be the
reasons for these poor predictions
but it's not that one thing jumped out
like this is the key problem but I mean
the world is complex right and this is
just a high prediction problem and so
coming back to my job Seeker question
like which job I should go into
nothing is a hard problem you know and
and if I look at these very I mean that
those aren't data that we are using that
have 12 000 variables to pick from
whether they have beginning and end date
of my last job and whether I'm German
National and how old I am and what money
I made and the company size and nothing
that's about it and okay for a long time
series but it's just very
and so we can algorize my way yeah and
it could still be a very poor prediction
and in which case hesitation outside of
the population that this should be
actually used
that's understandable okay yet the
question is the human is the human any
better probably not right I mean that's
and so for me it's always it Compares
it's like okay what are we doing then
maybe we should this should all be
lottery I don't know right I mean yeah
sorry
I think that's a very reasonable
question to ask I think something that I
think of a lot of the time when I think
about a similar question is how uh how
expensive is each decision-making
process right like if we're trying to
reach some greater goal outside of that
are the
business strategy towards my model to
make the decision that humans could also
make or is there like
to achieve a fairness goal by allocating
yeah I I love that you bring the cost
element in it I think that's very
interesting in the survey context
you know good high quality data to
collect very expensive right and
everyone is like oh let's use the
Olympic data sources but you're just
shifting the money from the expensive
interview to the uh the cheap interviews
to the expensive data scientists that
then try to like
right now I feel like in the prediction
context we're in a similar stage right I
mean yeah you can hire the mechanisms
and you know get them to help the
employment agency to create these models
or you know improve the process all
together there are a lot of different
ways but it's difficult to decide sort
of the car I mean so the actual cost of
making that decision but then also of
course the cost of the decision what
happens afterwards right if it isn't
that's why we did this differentiation
between the punitive and the
um assistive positions because I feel
like as long as it's helping and so
you're either the same as before or
helping then maybe we don't need to
think about it
although your story showed me that maybe
we do need to think about the helping um
with the students that even even
assistive actions could uh could be seen
as unclear if only some other people get
that yeah sorry my question is
from the past or Batman because mode is
present is something that we were able
to predict perfectly but that was a sign
that we couldn't interpret really well
and here we cannot predict really though
maybe that means we can intervene with
them and maybe that means that
prediction has a really good value here
so and and asking is it a good
observation to see we cannot predict
something
so for the social
jumps out on that but I my inner
direction is like for the social
scientists it they we never but we're
bothered by the fact that we can only
predictions I mean at the ashware is
because it was all the interest was in
sort of relative effects right the the
you your parents education what does
that do to your own outcome and you know
is it moving you up a little bit Yeah
okay affected small but you know it was
all about the relative effects of these
things right and so so
yeah I mean it depends on what the goal
is of what you're trying to do you have
you're evaluating the effectiveness of a
certain intervention right or or other
covariates you know relative to each
other then then that might be less
important the one remark about this um
data set
um
so to the extent that there was any
signal it was in four features and the
features were all about the mother and
so
um it was basically also an example of
something where
whatever signal there is was already
there before the um
let's did anything and so I think here
the thing that made this so kind of hard
to made it look so so bad in terms of
predictive accuracy is this time gap
between 6 and 15.
what this is sort of like ignoring and
that's maybe like a little bit of an
issue I have with the takeaway from this
paper is that there could still be a lot
of you know things you know that are
socially sort of uh uh constituted and
determined uh in in sort of uh you know
uh
um in the data right or like in these
variables that we're looking at right
and so I think
this shouldn't be some kind of feed this
takeaway right the takeaway could also
be like uh we know exactly uh what
constitutes hardship and you know it's
these these environments are right it's
just sort of like you don't see that
when you're trying to predict
GPA at age 15 from GTA to H6 absolutely
that's why for me
the focus and the core focus of the tip
I do and that's why I started out with
the data right I think it I mean
we use for these algorithms and
prediction of the data we have right and
and not necessarily thinking about that
very problem that you just described
right and of course in the setting where
you know that's why it works well on the
internet platforms you know it's like
okay see this this segment I click the
next second that's those are strong
strong and strong predictive legs right
and and a lot of the social science data
the the better ones are so expensive to
collect that between data collection and
releases of the year or two right you're
already having a big gap I mean it's not
as big as H9 to then 15 and they it was
such big gap because they wanted to have
data in there that everyone released and
no one has seen before and whatnot and
it would be very interesting to see
indeed uh for Corsa but that's why I led
with the you know
my somewhat flippant comment on all
sociology papers feel like they have a
point to uh Square even in other
settings we see that right it is it's
just just you know and and yeah most
data collections have this big gap
between
um uh collection and action that you're
trying to do in the employment in the
administrative data often don't are not
made available you know that quickly I
mean digitalization if you're not in
Estonia everywhere else sort of a little
bit slow you know to get to the data and
um but but I mean it's a word of caution
that you really have to
make sure that you know the those data
are useful and relevant and some of the
historic ones might just not be yeah so
thanks for finding that out I agree with
you I I didn't
I'm definitely in the camp of this is
worth my work doing not in the camp but
we shouldn't do any prediction models
right it's really just we should think
about that whole Pipeline and so I'm
closing out uh just with one uh um two
comments on that infrastructure
in order for the data to be used more
faster you know more easily and with all
the variables available
it is important to get environments in
which we can do that and not you know
wait forever until they are anonymized
and available to the public and what
have you right I mean I I'm again here
too in full support of the open data
movement but
it slows things down for certain
settings and instead you know and it
often doesn't allow to look at
measurement inconsistencies and errors
in the data and what have you so
creating environments in which you can
do this safely but on the actual data
right when they arise would be a
necessary infrastructure piece and there
have been initiatives
um that do that we started this coverage
initiative that that has basically a set
of well a lot of States data are pulled
together and uh can can be analyzed that
way in a safe environment and um and and
what we're trying to do in that is to
follow these new guidelines from CNS
that on the transparency all the
decision like basically back to Emily's
talk all the decisions that have been
made so that you can access the the code
in addition
um with the data and understand that so
uh my takeaway is not at all uh
predictions are poor don't do it or
follow the polls but but more we need to
look at the data and uh we
um we need to just think about that data
space in conjunction with the algorithms
if we want to move forward
means
[Music]
um
there was a few things that it was an
explanation
with them but let's say why the
algorithm inside
what
uh why some decisions
you know I do think that a lot could be
done differently how we ask them right
and how I mean I started out with these
guiding principles I mean we don't even
agree what does fair mean right is it
everyone gets the same everything this
is really nebulous and in this case it
was on purpose because that's how we
commonly talk about it and that's how
people discuss about it and our Focus
was really just the difference that a
context made you know but yes I'm in
sort of if you're trying to actually get
at what people perceive as fair that
would be a different type of study and
that would issue a different instrument
and then and I think there's a lot of
interesting work to be done as we move
towards explainability you know it's
like when when does it I mean maybe it's
fair when I can look inside now now can
understand what happens right
I have a question so you framed this
very nicely in the beginning and like
that's a lot um in some sense
human versus algorithm is a bit of a
strawment and the actual question is
we're always talking about institutions
and we're really interested in like what
happens to institutions as we increase
the degree of rationalization or the
degree of borrow credit
uh and the degree of sort of Predictive
Technologies that are used within the
institution to make decisions so I've
actually I've always been running for
sociology to give us the answer how we
should think about this and how we
should evaluate what happens as we dial
the knob within an institution
um do you have any thoughts on how to
study that rather than just like yeah it
is it strong and that I got from
Oma because he said why don't you give a
talk with that type of nurse it was a
little bit like that but I thought
actually it is good because the
discussion is always should we do this
what do we do the human I mean we are
discussing it in these terms but I agree
with you what I didn't get to do is sort
of talk about
um
what I think happens and that's why I
brought in the infrastructure a little
bit at the end time for the result is
that Elon has to do with trust right
trust in the institution and the humans
in the institution they're just seen as
part of the institution and so there's a
lot of tremendous plenty of room on
these jobs and it's not being good
enough but by and large there's Trust on
what they do and then of course as you
change that bring in technology that
changes and then it's the questions
who's building the technology and the
like so I think that would be very
interesting to look at I haven't seen
convincing studies yet but I I
um it would be around trust that I would
study this
to give a short answer to your questions